Do we need to go back to Charlemagne to
tie the bow on Charlemagne?
>> No, no, not really. I mean, you know, he
he's great for his own thing. Charles
the Great. I'll give you one quick
anecdote again because it shows you the
games they play. So, uh, it's known that
he and Haron Rashid, the Khalif, the
Abbassad Khalif had good relations.
Okay. [snorts] And people use this often
as oi.
>> And where was that Khalif based?
>> Uh, Baghdad.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, the Abbassad caliphate. And and then
we're talking now, you know, the year
800 or a little after. And people will
always show you, yeah, see it's, you
know, Islam and Christians got along.
You got two, you got two emperors or a
khalif and an emperor, and they were
friends, etc., etc., and they gave gifts
to one each other. But when you dig in
and you read the chronicles and I quoted
I'm pretty sure in Sword and Scaria I I
discuss um his the chronicler of
Charlemagne, he makes it perfectly clear
that the reason Charlemagne was being
nice and reaching out to Haron Rasheed
was to was in almost like he was bribing
him to be good to the Christians under
his authority in Egypt, in Iraq, in in
the Islamic world because there were so
many Christians. Mhm.
>> So he says that the chronicler he says
the reason he sought out friendships was
so he can make the plight of Christians
living in those regions less and he can
help them. Okay. So you see how again
that is omitted but we're told about oh
look they got along because Muslims and
Christians always get along.
>> You know that's I can leave it at that
with Charlemagne.
>> So uh then let's go to the Crusades.
Yeah.
>> This is quite a a whistleblow tour.
Yeah. Um so it's 1095. So 1095, but we
have to start a little earlier to give
context. So you know, everything I
discussed was during the Arab the rise
of the Arab Empire and it went through
iterations. You had the Omiads and then
you had the Abbasids which I just
mentioned. Um and then sometime after
that, you know, the the the the
Abbassads start importing Turkish slaves
and Islamizing them, slave soldiers,
okay, like the Janiseries and the
Mamlukes. Um, and you know, long story
short, before long, you know, the Turks
become very Muslim and they become Sunni
Muslims. Um, which is important because
we're going to talk a little bit about
Shia. And, um, eventually they take over
and they still keep the caliphate, the
Abbassid, but he's more of a puppet
figure. And the real power is the Seljic
Sultan. All right. Now, during this
time, especially from like 1050 to 1090,
okay, right before the first crusade,
these Seljixs are running a muk. Okay?
So the persecution and the destruction
of Christians that I mentioned earlier
under the Arabs times 10. I mean now
it's just it's horrific. Okay. They
start in Armenia, greater Armenia which
is you know far what we would say
eastern Anatolia and according to the
records you know I'm thinking of Matthew
of Adessa who was a contemporary. They
were just killing tens of thousands of
Christians Armenians Greeks okay and
burning every church in Ani which was
the capital at the time of Armenia. It
was known as the city of a thousand1
churches. They ritually burned down
every church, destroyed every crucifix.
I tell you that to also underscore
because a lot of people will tell you,
okay, the Turks, you know, it's people
were waring. It's different tribes and
they try to um, you know, minimize the
religious element. So that's why I'm
telling you that in their own sources,
it it's very clear that they did what
ISIS would do. They symbolically were
trying to denigrate Christianity. They
would destroy churches. They would take
the greatest cross of the greatest
church and send it as a war trophy to
Baghdad to the Khalif. Okay, so my point
is it wasn't just warfare. It was it had
that jihadist ideological component.
Okay, which again historians like to
just ignore as some sort of you know
whatever, but it's in the sources.
>> And [snorts] um they were also in the
Holy Land. You know, you had pilgrims
that were always going to the Holy Land
even though it was a hard venture and
they would get persecuted even before
that under the Arabs in the seventh,
8th, 9th centuries. Now the Turks really
took a new level and you know they would
attack the pilgrims. They would extort
even more money than they had to pay.
There's one instant incident that
happened in 1065 which really was a
scandal. They attacked a large German
pilgrimage and they gang rape the nun
and you know made everyone watch it like
really horrific stuff. They would go in
churches and disembowel people and just
smear the blood on the altar again as a
form of mockery. Okay. So this is this
is what's building up towards the first
crusade. And then um it really gets bad
after the battle of Manzert, which is
one of my main battles also in in my
book Sword and Scimitar. [snorts] And
the Christians again lose.
>> Where is that battle?
>> It's in Manzakert, which is actually
close to Armenia in Asia Minor. Um the
Roman emperor at the time went trying
again like Yarmmuk, they went with a
large army trying to stop these the
Seljuk Turks and they lost. And after
that they just completely ran a muck all
westward and now they're attacking all
Asia Minor of course I mean Turkey what
we call now it's Turkey because it got
conquered during this time. Um and Asia
Minor by the way you know so Turkey when
you hear Turkey you think okay it's a
Muslim nation this is this was such a
Christian nation that you know St.
Paul's letters, most of them go there.
Asia Minor, yeah,
>> a lot of them. And uh so now it's all
conquered and now they're right next to
Constantinople and they're on the verge
of actually reaching and getting into
the European mainland. and the emperor,
the Roman emperor at the time, Alexis,
he calls for aid from the Franks and the
you know the Europe and he had friends
there and you know some nobles and they
all got together and long story short
Pope Pope Urban II at the council of
Claremont in 1095 in November he
basically stood up and he told
everything that was happening he
mentioned everything I'm telling you all
the desecrations of churches all the
rape of women and the sl and the forced
Islamization of children and the
disembowling of Christians very graphic
stuff. Okay. And which is in a lot of
sources. So it's not, you know, one guy
knitted up. Um, and that's it. And they
all cried out Deos Vult, which Mr.
Hexath has a a tattoo on, which means
God wills it, right? And that was it.
They they they went. So if you ask
earlier historians, you know, in the
1800s, they would tell you the crusades
were motivated by love. You know they
were actually in a lot of the it comes
out in some of the sources where the
crusaders were moved by Christ's
injunction to love your fellow man as
much as yourself and to love God. So
they were loving God because they wanted
to go and liberate the holy selectric.
They wanted to liberate the holy land
which was very important. You again this
is something modern people don't
understand but um place was important
you know holy sacred land was something
that was you know very important. So
they wanted to go and liberate it from
Muslim control and they wanted to also
protect fellow Christians. And now you
know your average person, you hear the
word crusade, it's such a diabolical
evil thing, evil venture.
>> But that marks an interesting turning
point from the Christian point of view
from this let's say turn the other cheek
mentality to we're going to protect our
fellow Christians by killing others.
>> Yeah. So the the whole issue, you know,
this goes back to the concept of just
war, which really one of the name that
always gets thrown out there and it's
it's the chief articulator they would
say and proponent is Augustine, St.
Augustine, who lived in the fourth
century, okay? Um or it was a fifth
century. So he's way before all this.
And to him and to almost every other
doctor of the church and theologian, it
was okay to fight back. And you know
they would cite things like um you know
Roman centurion comes to Jesus and uh
Jesus heals his servant and then Jesus
you know what does Jesus do when he does
a miracle for someone? He tells him to
repent right change your way. He didn't
tell this guy hey put your sword away
stop killing. I mean this guy was a
centurion. He saw he oversaw the
bloodshed. A lot of bloodshed. Jesus
didn't say anything to him. Okay. So
also John the Baptist you know when
people came to him and a bunch of
soldiers came to him and saying what
must we do he didn't tell them leave the
army he said don't don't be content with
your pay okay so a lot of these were
understood by early church theologians
as justifying just war theory as long as
the war is not about you know conquest
and enforcing whatever my will on you if
I'm defending my land that was 100%
Christian okay and so and this is why
okay so if you don't understand
everything everything I've been saying
if you didn't hear this then how is
crusades just war because what you see
is a bunch of Europeans going to Muslim
territory what's just in that but if you
know the truth which is well that was
Christian territory and they were
killing Christians still and destroying
Christian lands and holy sacred places
then it did become part of the just war
theory you see what I'm saying
>> but it's 300 years since that it had
been Muslim
>> yeah but I mean to their thinking
>> to their point of view
>> and it was still full of Christians and
you know I mean I don't think they they
went by what's it like statues of
limitations, right? They didn't think
that way, you know. So, okay.
>> So, in their mind, I'm they still
rationalized it, but but specifically it
was because they were killing Christians
and attacking Christians places. Okay.
So, that was it.
>> Even if it wasn't Christian beforehand,
I think they would have just war theory
would cover the logic. Why are you
killing innocent Christians?